on vient sur l'île de montréal de
nouvelles entraves à la circulation
cette fois ça concerne l'autoroute 15
tout juste à la sortie du prochain plaît
du côté de montréal jacques bissonnet
ont fait des travaux préparatoires on
l'a vu sur les images en vue de
l'élargissement de l'autoroute elle se
fait ici majeur patrice ans parce
qu'avec la démolition et reconstruction
de turcot plus ces travaux semblables
sur la caisse le corridor qui mène au
pont champlain mais c'est considéré
comme étant un des chantiers à des
chantiers en fait des infrastructures
les plus importants en amérique du nord
donc c'est pas bien alors évidemment on
l'aura deviné rats il va y avoir des
problèmes des entraves et ça commence
d'ailleurs demain soir alors l'autoroute
15 en direction nord donc les gens qui
arrivent des rives sud sera complètement
fermée demain soir à partir de 22h
jusqu'à mercredi matin 5 heures entre la
sortie wellington et l'avenue atwater le
détour se fera par l'autoroute
bonaventure et mercredi ce sera le
contraire en fait l'autoroute 15 en
direction sud cette fois alors sera
fermée entre la rue wellington et le
boulevard île des soeurs de 22 heures
mercredi soir à 5 heures jeudi matin
avec le des taux toujours par
bonaventure et là ce sont encore plus
longs comme des tours et s'est pas
terminée on a appris aujourd'hui qu'à
partir de la mi avril
eh bien il va y avoir des travaux
majeurs temporaire parce qu'on voyait
largeur effectivement l'autoroute 15
alors évidemment ce sera évitée même si
le responsable des projets se faire
rassurant
c'est ce que plus qu'on va avancer le
projet
plus vous y avoir d'impact gérer dont
notamment la gestion de circulation mais
ce qui est important de comprendre c'est
comme une obligation de garder la
circulation aux flux et de la mesure du
possible il faut s'attendre au pire
parce que déjà en ce moment alors que
les travaux sont pas vraiment commencé
le pont champlain est on le sait c'est
déjà la congestion et le matin et
l'après midi et l'après-midi et ben
c'est justement le secteur qui sera
touchée à partir du printemps 2016 s'il
faut qu'on rajoute aussi des travaux
pour mercier on a des travaux qui s'en
viennent au tunnel lafontaine ça risque
d'être catastrophique
juste un mot que plusieurs
automobilistes emploi le matin et
d'autres mots également faut rappeler
jean que les travaux les échéanciers
pour le pont ça va bon train quand même
ouais selon signature sur le fleuve
c'est l'organisme qui est responsable
des travaux affirme qu'on est en avance
sur les travaux alors je vous rappelle
que c'est un chantier de 4 milliards de
dollars que le pont le nouveau pont
champlain devrait ouvrir en décembre
2018 et les voies d'accès à ce pont à
l'automne 2010 9 adore entre temps et
bien les automobilistes devront s'armer
de patience merci jacques vous appris à
voir